Probably a year ago this became really popular right this little bottle flip thing
where you just flip a bottle
and it happens to supposed to drop if you do it just right like that and
What's fascinating is that it seems like this is a
Huge thing of luck. I can just sit here and do this all day long
Right.
It's just this massive thing of luck that I just happen to be getting lucky when I
actually get the bottle to flip correctly
But the reality is that's not necessarily luck
Apparently it's not skill on the part of myself either
however
After a little bit of research you find that there this is actually more of a fine
tuning thing
There's actually science behind the bottle flip
That it has something to do with the the size of the water bottle this one being
much too small
The amount of water that's in the bottle and how much spin you actually put on it
And if you get it right every single time and you have just the right amount of spin
And you have just about right amount of water and just the right bottle
You can never miss and based on science. It'll always land the way it's supposed to
see
We learned from Genesis that this world was created by God
We we know that right and we know that God designed it for us
but what if we really didn't have
Scripture to tell us that I mean this tells me that God designed the world
This tells me that God did it all and all I have to do is look at this and go.
Yeah, okay
I know that but what if I didn't have it
What does this?
Tell me about God's design what it tells me is the same thing that nature tells me
That all of this fine-tuning all of these things that we have
Just right just
calculated just so
So that we could actually survive here so that we could thrive so we could live and
breathe and do all the things that we do
And we can have this earth spinning in this universe around the Sun and all the way
the ways that
Most of us kind of just accept and take for granted and don't worry too much about
Is this really about random chance?
Did this world just sort of pop into existence and things just happened a
Fall in the right way that if I flip this bottle enough times that this universe
just kept starting and
Restarting and restarting and restarting until one day it actually worked and
See this is this is there now the universe worked
Is that what this or is this a well-crafted design by God?
That's what this unit is about but that's this lesson is about this lesson is about
looking at our universe and seeing
That this is more than just a random whole bunch of stuff that happened to fall into
place the right place at the right time
but instead an actual design and science
Behind crafting the right conditions for life to happen
So for this week, I want you to think about one word. I want you to think
about thinking
Last week we kind of introduced the idea that science actually furthers our faith
and lays a crucial foundation
For what we believe
It's great. Well, this is where we start to see that happen
This is where we start to actually have to start thinking about some of these things
and
Start putting some pieces together
Think about more than just the the thinking cognitive piece of this and the stuff
that you can know
But take a second and think through this for a second
What does it mean that?
God has made a place for us
If you stop and consider this for just one minute
All of these things with the atmosphere the earth's rotation the distance from the
Sun whatever it is
These things are just so
So that we can live here we can thrive here that if God designed this it doesn't
just prove or show
Evidence that God exists
It doesn't just prove that God gave us a place where it's
It's habitable for us to actually just survive here
But it's made in such a way
That God has created a home for us
And he did it with with with his heart and with love in mind
I mean, what does this say about who God is?
What does fine-tuning say about the character of God?